welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with an
emerging front in the gun control debate
so-called red flag laws allow courts to
confiscate weapons from people found to
be at risk of harming themselves or
others
today seventeen states and the District
of Columbia have passed such measures
gun rights groups have fought against
them but some say a major loss in
Colorado this year may be a sign of
things to come
Barry Petersen has the story above
Colorado's capital the flags are still
at half-staff for Dayton and El Paso and
Tom Sullivan freshman member of the
state's legislature still has his seat
and still works for stricter gun control
laws are you confident that will happen
because you actually faced the gun
rights lobby and won yes yes and I am
energized by the fact that our young
people are getting on board with this
Sullivan's son Alex was killed in
another mass shooting the theater
massacre in Aurora Sullivan supported
Colorado's new red flag law we're
running a circulation for a recall
effort so gun rights groups launched a
recall but gave up facing little public
support these are all machine guns on
this wall legal machine guns except for
this which is a grenade launcher
Dudley Brown runs Rocky Mountain Gun
Owners the group that led the recall did
you fail your job because he wasn't
recalled news flash we can't bat 100 100
or 1000 and gun rights groups suffered
another setback this week from President
Trump that is why I have called for a
red flag laws also known as extreme risk
protection orders we're gonna say call
him and tell him what you think of his
betrayal of principles and and his base
John Wars
too extreme for Colorado to Cold War's
September 10 just six years ago gun
rights groups won their recall of John
Morris then president of the Colorado
Senate I am happy that recall against
Tom Sullivan fell apart and I'm hoping
that that boosts the courage of those
politicians that are still just
pandering politicians but now pander to
gun safety instead of pander away from
it because we are so tired of burying
our children there's going to be more
parents of Murdered Children running for
office and we're all going to take
offices local levels state levels and in
Washington DC gun rights groups are now
trying to recall Colorado's governor
jared Polis but polls show this may be
another try
ending in another failure for CBS this
morning Saturday Barry Petersen Denver
do you need a grenade launcher yeah that
was interesting as to anti-terrorism
operation I mean some very serious
issues being discussed here but
interesting video yeah we just saw from
Barry's piece there I mean this is such
has been such an intractable issue in
Washington and one has to wonder whether
or not these recent mass shootings that
we've seen have actually changed the
dynamic at all so it's been fascinating
to see what took place there in Colorado
yeah and if it can't things can't get
done on the national level fast enough
maybe on the state level there are some
changes that people can make